FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
Good afternoon.
Thank you, again, for coming
to one of our most recent NASA
at Google Talks.
We do these monthly, so it's
good to see some familiar faces
coming back again and again.
Today, we have something
really special.
Dr. George Nelson is here from
the International Space Station
project.
This is a live stream
of the Space Station.
That's what we're
looking at right now.
Originally from Maine, Dr.
Nelson's affiliation with NASA
began in 1998 as a graduate
student research fellow.
He began a full-time
NASA career in 2001
in the training of flight
controllers and as-- sorry,
and astronauts on the electrical
and thermal systems of the ISS.
After serving as the
Configuration Manager
for the Space Station
through much of the assembly,
he began his current tenure as
manager of the Space Station
Technology Demonstration
Office, through which
all of the engineering
and technology research
is conducted on
the Space Station.
He's based in Houston currently.
And without further
ado, Dr. George Nelson.
GEORGE NELSON: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi.
Thanks for coming, guys.
As she said, this is
a live view from ISS.
It's from a payload, which
is our term for an experiment
or an investigation
on ISS called HDEV
for high-definition
Earth viewing.
And we're looking aft.
You can see a couple of
Russian transport vehicles.
The Canadarm is
there, as well as
just a tiny bit of
the US segment there.
We're flying over the Pacific,
and I had a tracker up here.
We're flying over
the Pacific, and I
think we're headed south by
now, and we're about to-- yeah,
we're headed south.
We're pretty close to
the Hawaiian Islands,
and we won't really
see any land probably
until we cross maybe southern
Patagonia in a while.
But because of the way
we got this set up,
I'm going to take this down
and throw up some slides there
for you.
And this is available any time
you guys want to look at it.
We stream it 24 hours a day.
When you're at night, you
don't really see very much.
We have the cameras not
tuned to pick up city lights
or-- you can't see
any stars or anything.
But we had this
specifically to test out
some sensors for different
commercial off-the-shelf
cameras.
So there's four
different cameras.
There's two looking aft,
one looking forward,
and one looking down and
a little bit to starboard.
So they rotate through,
and we take a look,
and they've held up a
lot better than we really
thought they would.
There's a couple of CMOS and a
couple of CCD sensors on there.
The radiation environment
is not very nice there,
so we didn't expect
it to last too long,
but they've been doing OK.
We don't really even see any
pixel degradation as of yet.
So if you go to ustream.tv
and search for HDEV,
that's where you can find
this feed any time you want.
All right.
OK.
So when Terry Fong
and Chris Provencher
asked me, what's the
title of your talk,
I thought, oh, I've got
to come up with a title.
I guess I should find
one that really grabs
people, something
of some interest.
And I thought that maybe
How to Travel Through Time
with the ISS, but then I
realized that, you know,
maybe I need to ground it
a little better in reality.
Although, for the relativistic
time guys out there,
I got something for
you a little bit later.
And then, there's a lot of
things you can do on ISS,
but trying to identify bubbles
in commodities or other stock
markets-- no one has yet
proposed that that's something
that you really can do.
So I ended up going with "How
Best to Use Your Neighborhood
Space Station."
And I came to that by
saying that there's
a lot of ideas on
how to best use it.
And we're talking philosophy.
We're talking
specific experiments,
how to fund everything
that we're doing.
And the fact that
it really is yours.
So the whole thing was
built with taxpayer dollars.
Whether you're from
the United States
or you're from a European ESA
country, or Canada, or Japan,
or Russia, it was all built
with taxpayer dollars.
So it really is
yours, and the way
that the United
States has it set up
is that you even have
direct access to it
through a mechanism that I'll
explain a little bit later
for you.
But it's open to United States
corporate and private entities
to help the tax base
of the United States.
If you got a great
idea and you're
going to end up making
money on the ground
after proving
something out on ISS
and you're going to hire
Americans who pay taxes
and make the world better,
we're there for you,
and we hope you get to use it.
And then, being a
neighborhood space station,
when you look at
the cosmos overall,
it is definitely in
our neighborhood.
And really, it's only a
couple hundred miles up,
so it's pretty close by.
We provide you access for it.
And if you guys provide the
things to do on it, well, then,
that's one of the best ways you
can use your neighborhood space
station.
So the vehicle itself
that you just saw,
that's about the same
location, a little bit
further south as
we are right now.
This was yesterday morning.
It passed over-- you can see,
if you've ever compared it
to a shuttle flight before
we started building ISS,
this goes to much
higher latitudes
than the shuttle normally did.
And that's because we
wanted to have access
from our Russian partners
who launch out of Kazakhstan.
And then, they try and
launch over the top of China,
rather than-- or rather,
north of China, rather than
directly over the top of them.
So that's the
inclination that we have,
and so that sets up
the angle that you
see the orbital track
takes to the equator.
OK, so I want to
talk a little bit
about what it took to build
the Space Station so that you
guys understand the challenges
that NASA and the program
itself have been trying to
tackle in properly using it.
So I think the Russian
number is actually from July,
so I think you could say
that that's either 98
or 99 now total
Russian launches.
Most of those have been
unmanned progress, which
is the resupply vehicle from
the Russian Space Agency,
or the Soyuz spacecraft that
can take up and down three
astronauts, or cosmonauts.
And that's also the primary
lifeboat-- the only lifeboat
that we have for the ISS in
an emergency to get back home.
37 space shuttle launches--
so you look at it,
you think about how many we had.
That's about a fourth of all
the space shuttle launches
that we did was for ISS.
It was the real workhorse.
It was the original intent
of the space shuttle program
to build a space station-- had
a big payload bay to bring up
all the parts.
We flew the Japanese module
that the Japanese built.
We flew the European module
that the Europeans built.
We built-- we flew two modules
that the Europeans built
for us in exchange for
flying their module--
and a huge American
segment as well.
We've flown some
commercial vehicles as
of late there as well.
You know Elon's
effort through SpaceX.
And Orbital space
sciences-- Orbital Sciences
is also flying commercial
vehicles to ISS, unmanned
and in a resupply fashion
for all the utilization, all
the experiments that we
try and conduct there.
The Japanese have
flown four HTVs,
and the Europeans
have flown five ATVs.
Those are also both unmanned.
The difference between
the two-- Europe launches
from down near the equator,
off of South America.
Japan launches from an
island called Tanegashima.
The ATV uses a Russian
system to dock autonomously
in the same way that
their progress docks
to the station, and the HTV
rendezvous with the vehicle,
and then we grab it with
that Canadarm that you saw
and berth it to the
forward end of the vehicle.
So I talk about all
this to say this
was-- the very first
Russian launch was back
in November of '98.
Is that right, Chris?
November of '98 was
when the Russians first
launched the FGB.
Now, this was a section that
the United States largely
compensated Russia to build.
And then, with
the space shuttle,
we went up and attached
our Node 1 to it.
And then we waited
for quite a while
until the Russians were able
to build their service module.
And then it was a
habitable platform.
And since then, we've had
continuous human presence
on ISS.
So that's been since
2000-- I think also
at the very end of 2000, we've
had continuous human presence
up there.
And the amount of
effort and time
that it took just to build
the space station-- you
can imagine that
that was the focus.
Get it built.
And then especially when we put
a sunset clause on the space
shuttle program itself,
there was even more urgency.
Let's get it built.
Let's get this done first.
So that was the primary focus.
But now that it's built, using
it is the most important thing.
So any time that you spend that
much money and that much time,
you're going to have a
considerable amount of inertia
that you have to overcome.
And then you complicate
it with the fact
that it's a government project,
and you have even more.
So it's been challenging to do
the change that was required.
But what we did, as soon as
the space shuttle program ended
and we had fully
utilized its capability
to get us ready
to be without it,
we reorganized a large part
of the space station program
in order to more properly
reflect the priorities
that we now have, which is doing
the science and engineering
research on board.
So prior to that day,
the payloads office
had largely its own--
they were self-contained.
They had their own
engineering support.
They were like their
own little program
because they were
just off on the side.
And Chris was with me,
doing a lot of the training
that we would do.
And in any simulation
that we would
run, as soon as a major
malfunction would happen,
one of the first things that
happens, turn off the payloads.
And so that kind of
ingrains into the flight
controllers and
everybody who's getting
trained at that
point that, look,
that is not the important thing.
The important thing
is making sure
that the facility
is still running.
Everything is OK.
The crew is safe.
We still care
about those things,
but the primary focus now has to
be on getting the science done.
So one of the things
we did is we got rid
of the separate program
aspect of all the science
that we're doing,
disseminated those individuals
throughout the program.
There were some
optics-type thing--
and I don't mean
optics the discipline.
I mean optics the--
just how things look.
By moving the program
scientists on the org chart
up next to the program manager--
the mail code for payloads
is OZ, so historically,
we've been
at the bottom right-hand
corner of every org chart.
That's moved up as well.
And we're still
working to make it
better because we've had
more than one accident where
we have loss of life.
So we have several decades
of work building up
processes that ensure safety.
But when you're trying to
do scientific research,
you don't need to necessarily
focus on mission success.
What you need to focus on--
the particular aspect of what
you're trying to discover.
So all the rigor and
extra money and cost
that goes with building
a typical spaceflight
project-- we don't want to
incur those costs in order
to do research and to use the
space station like the lab
next door.
And so I tell
everybody, you've got
to treat it like it's a
facility down the road,
and I'm paying for your
transportation costs.
I take care of the flight up.
We take care of the
crew being there.
power and the thermal
and the data, all the
stuff that you need.
All you've got to do is build
it so that it works for you,
not for us.
So we're still working
to fix our processes
so that you and even other
people within our own agency
have better access to
using the facility.
And one of the
things that we did
was we set up three offices.
So there was the
National Lab Office,
and so that's what
I alluded to before.
So anybody outside of NASA,
whether it's another government
agency, or a private
company or a public company,
or an individual who has a
good use for the Space Station
platform can go through
the National Lab Office.
And we hired a
not-for-profit entity
called CASIS, the Center
for Advancement of Science
In Space.
And one of the
reasons we want to do
it is we trust ourselves to
choose the right investments
that NASA cares about for
space flight and space
exploration and aero
sciences and the like,
but we didn't want 20 years from
now someone saying, you know,
we could have cured this
disease if you guys had only
let us fly on the ISS.
So we have this
not-for-profit entity
that hires the right experts
in all the different fields
where we're getting proposals
to properly vet, and evaluate,
and prioritize the
different things that
are being proposed
to fly on ISS.
So that's one way you can get up
there, through the National Lab
Office.
The second office that was
created was where I work,
the Technology
Demonstration Office.
So all the engineering
and technology research
that gets done on ISS flies
through this office, as well as
all the Department
of Defense work.
So that's kind of like the
caveat, the exception that
proves the rule for the
National Lab Office.
That's supposed to be all the
external to NASA government
agencies, but there's a peaceful
purposes clause for ISS,
and so all the work the
DOD does is peaceful work.
And so that's directly in
line with all of NASA's needs.
So for accounting and
stuff, we keep the DOD stuff
as part of a national
lab utilization,
but in practice, it
all flows through us.
And the third office
that we came up with
was the Science Research Office.
So there's this whole section
of the agency called the Science
Mission Directorate.
And so these are the guys
that fund the rovers on Mars
and the Hubble and the
Webb Space Telescope,
and do a lot of great stuff.
But they have their own
bureaucracy, their own vetting
of what they want to do.
And all of their work,
and all of the work
that they fund outside
the agency as well,
flows through that
particular office.
So one of the
first things we did
was set up those
three front doors.
Let's see.
Part of the change that
I said was challenging
was reminding everybody
who the customer is.
So when you work in
a government agency,
while you work for the
citizens of the country,
you often consider yourself
to be the customer.
You're working for the
people, but the contractor
who's supplying you
with something--
they need to understand
you're the customer.
But now we're
completely different.
When we're running
the Space Station,
we're not the customer anymore.
The customers are the
principal investigators
across the country-- and
world, in our case-- that
are trying to do work there.
So reminding everybody of
that and reminding people
that this is not the last space
program or the one before that
even, where you have a mentality
that worked very well for us
of "failure is not an option."
But in this case, that's
a very difficult way
to run a research program.
If you look at some of the more
aggressive research programs
like the DARPA runs, failure
is almost a necessity.
If they are too successful
in the portfolio
that they're investing in, the
people get a talking to, like,
"I don't think you're
taking enough risks."
So the risks that
we want everybody
to accept with using ISS
are not safety risks.
We're not asking to put the
crew or the vehicle at risk.
But making bold steps and
taking risks technically
to see if we can come up
with the best solutions
is exactly something that
we want to encourage.
So while we've become this
customer service organization
and we continue to help
everybody figure that out,
we've tried to help change the
attitudes just with everybody
that we work with every day.
So a standard conversation,
as you're walking across
in between buildings at
Johnson Space Center, would be,
did you hear about effort X?
They needed three
times to get that done.
Can you believe?
Why couldn't they get
that tested on the ground?
Why couldn't they
figure that out?
And that's exactly
the type of attitude
that we're trying to
change a little bit,
where it's OK to have
iterative tasks on orbit.
We have a crew
there for a reason.
You can build
something and fly it.
And if it didn't
work the way it was
supposed to, well, how many
times have you been in a lab
and it worked the
first time, every time?
And that's really
expensive, if that's
the way you want to operate.
So we're trying to get people
to accept that this is a lab,
and it doesn't necessarily work
the first time, every time.
And when you discover
how it goes wrong,
that's the benefit
of using the lab.
So what kind of things
can you do up there?
I'm talking about
all of these things
that you should and could do.
What kind of things
can you do there?
Well, let's look at a few things
that we're already doing up
there and kind of split it down
the middle between non-NASA
and NASA.
So there's biology and
biotechnology investigations
that are up there.
They're on both sides.
Most of the human research
has been funded by NASA.
There is not a lot
of commercial need
identified yet with
people spending money--
their own money-- on trying to
figure out the human effects.
And it's of great
importance for NASA
if we're going to take
long-duration missions to Mars,
for example.
The physical sciences
are funded both by NASA
and by other
government agencies.
Technology demonstrations--
that's one of the things
that I spend a lot of time
harping on other entities
about, is the fact that this
is a lab that can be used.
It's really difficult within
the aerospace community
to change the paradigm that most
executives in most aerospace
companies are used to.
That paradigm is we'd love to
do something for you, NASA,
and we'd love you
to pay us to do it.
So I'm trying to
get to the point
where they're investing
their own money
and keeping their
intellectual property
and utilizing this national
asset at the same time.
So it's a tough
thing to convince
people of because the
performance period
cycle of that particular
vice-president
is probably shorter than
the return on investment
for whatever they're going
to fly to ISS and test out.
And then, when we
finally decide that we're
going to go back to the
moon or to Mars one day,
we buy that one because
it did so well on ISS.
So that VP is long gone by the
time his company gets that ROI,
and so getting to
the right level
of the different companies
and the different corporations
and getting them to
accept this possibility
has been a challenge.
We're getting there,
and I think you'll
see some things coming up soon.
What else?
Astrophysics-- that's kind
of NASA's mandate, right?
So we fund the astrophysics
work that gets done up there.
Earth science-- there's a
lot of different things,
both funded by NASA and not.
We'll talk a couple
examples about that later.
And then on the
education side, you guys
work for one of the entities
that does an awful lot of work
in that area, and NASA
tries to use the assets
that we have to do the
same sort of thing.
So some of the-- you may have
seen some videos or pictures
of astronauts working
inside the station.
As an exposure facility, we
have a lot of options on ISS.
And outside the vehicle,
we have four logistics
carriers-- one,
two, three, four.
They're on the main
truss that goes across.
That was all part of the
United States' contribution.
And on those, we
have some spare parts
that we flew up there that
were so big that we knew
we needed to fly them up
on the space shuttle first,
so we have those
pre-positioned when
we have to remove and
replace the originals.
But we have a lot of
payload spots on there.
So some of the different
things that you can do up there
is look up, or look down,
or take material testing
in that environment.
There's a lot of
atomic oxygen there.
There's, as I said before,
the radiation environment.
If you want to do other
things in this area,
you need to make sure that
your materials are going
to respond over periods
of time, and respond well.
Both the Japanese
and the Europeans
have exposed facilities that
they have the opportunity
to put stuff on.
The United States has access
to both of those facilities
as well.
And then, we have
some specific areas
that we've placed different
investigations like the AMS is
not on an ELC, but it's
out there on the truss,
and we'll talk about that
a little bit later too.
And the Russians have their own
investigative program as well.
By far, it seems the United
States and its partners
have invested more so far
in the research side of ISS.
So why would we take
all this time and money
to do this sort of thing?
Well, it's the
concept that nations
explore in order to advance.
And the exploration can come
from physically going somewhere
to explore or just
for their observation
of either natural phenomenon
or things that you can observe.
And that exploration drives
technology breakthroughs
and scientific discoveries.
And without that exploration,
that cycle of improvement
can be broken.
But the ISS partnership,
in the fact that it really
spans the globe, has
transformed space exploration
from an effort for
the advancement
of individual nations,
like Russia, United States
in the '60s, and China right
now, to an endeavor to-- it's
"committed to the
advancement of humankind."
And I read that directly because
it's a pretty heady statement,
right?
Get a hold of yourself.
But the reason it's justified
is the fact that we have,
just as of last year,
almost 70 countries
who've managed to
participate in ISS, using it.
Not just the
partnership countries--
so you can see the
four main partners
at the top of that ring, the
United States, Canada, Japan,
and Russia, and then
the rest of the ESA
represented countries in
the rest of the flags,
and then all the
other participants
that I mentioned on the side.
So we've gotten a
lot of use of the ISS
so far across the
world, and it can
have a significantly
stabilizing effect
beyond just individual or
principal investigators
from different
countries collaborating.
So carrying on with
the humans explore
concept-- so they explore
in order to advance.
So you can debate
all you want about
Columbus's initial intentions
or final intentions,
but it's hard to debate
about the influence
that his initial
trip had on Spain
and the subsequent
trips that continued.
He didn't go once and stop.
They went and continued to
go, and Spain significantly
left the Iberian
Peninsula and at one point
claimed nearly half the world.
In contrast, in the-- I
think it was the 1400s,
the Ming Dynasty had
sent out a large Naval
fleet that was larger than
anything the Portuguese were
sailing through
the Indian Ocean.
And then, when that monarch
died and his son took over,
he pulled back, and they
stopped the naval exploration.
And there's one train of thought
that says that that helped lead
to the Ming Dynasty's
end, was their lack
of continued
exploration, and they
weren't there when
the Portuguese came in
with much smaller boats.
And like I said, you can
observe from where you are,
or you can go there to
observe natural phenomenon.
If you look far enough, you
can see some interesting things
and gain something from it.
So you have Isaac Newton
proving everything
that he was looking
at by observing
the curvature of a comet,
and that led to calculus
and proving that.
And a lot of the missions
that actually went somewhere
to explore-- the
standard way to do that
was to bring a
naturalist with you,
a scientist or a naturalist.
So we have Captain Cook, and
it shows the resolution there.
I think his first trip
was on the Endeavor,
and that was to Tahiti to
observe the transit of Venus.
And so the big thing
there was trying
to discover, or to prove,
the size of the solar system.
And the problem is that
science takes a lot of time.
So they got back from that
trip, and the Royal Society
that had funded them, based on
the recommendation of Halley
several decades
before, were completely
unimpressed with the data
that they brought back.
This is no good at all.
But it turns out
that, later on, when
they were able to
double-check a lot of the work
in the next transit, they were
able to say that they were
within less than-- I know it
was less than half a percent
accuracy for the size
of the solar system.
So science takes longer
than the exploration itself.
In subsequent trips, he was
looking for a Northwest Passage
and found Hawaii.
I think that's a good
return on investment there.
On Darwin's trip, this was a
trip-- the trip of the Beagle,
the second one, the
one that Darwin was on,
he was observing a
lot of geology stuff.
And that was a trip
that was specific to map
the west coast of South America.
So it was a strict
exploration mission
to bring back cartography,
map out the west coast.
But Darwin noticed
sea shells at altitude
when he was ashore
and then noticed
a lot of the other
natural stuff.
And it wasn't till 20 years
later that "Origin of Species"
was actually published.
So my point about all
of this is that science
takes a longer period of time
than the specific exploration
that you're conducting.
So some of the things
that we're doing up
there-- biology, whether
it's an animal cell
or whether it's
a bacteria, we're
recognizing that, particularly
in things like gene expression,
that the microgravity
environment ends up
stressing the organism.
And that stressing
of the organism
ends up expressing
itself in genes.
The same way it does
in a large organism--
if you stress it a certain way,
certain things come out-- we're
recognizing the same thing
in observations on ISS.
And when you-- yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Do you have--
what's the radiation
environment inside the station?
Does that also affect
the expression?
GEORGE NELSON: It can, yeah.
And I think the one
that sticks in my mind
was that Shannon Lucid did
some work on Mir before we
had ISS that showed higher
rates of mutation on things.
But they try and back
that out and make sure
that what they're
looking at is this.
And the important thing
is not necessarily
that, oh, it's
microgravity that turned
this particular expression on.
It's recognizing that when
that gene is turned on,
this happens so
that you can then
go ahead and prevent that
or encourage that in order
to do what you need
to do on the ground.
But the ISS is considered
a radiation environment,
and the crew are considered
radiation workers.
So we do a lot of work on
monitoring the radiation
environment.
And I'll mention
that again a little
bit later, when we talk about
some of the technology stuff
that we're trying to do.
That enough?
OK.
OK, so other biology stuff--
just larger scale systems,
right?
So plants-- it'd
be nice if we could
be able to grow plants
on a transit mission.
So these are some of the
things that we're looking at.
But there's also
fundamental research
involved with some of the
work that we're doing.
We have plants up there.
Human physiology--
there's plenty
that goes on with the human
body when we're up there,
and some of them we've managed
to even start to overcome.
So we've had a lot of-- a
long time-- you've probably
heard about crew coming back
after a long-duration mission
basically with
osteoporosis, right?
So as soon as you
get up there, you
stop stressing particularly
your large bones
in your legs and your
back and your hips
because you're no longer loading
it every step of every day.
And your body's very
efficient, and it just
starts flushing everything
out, to the point
it was beyond what we even
thought of when we built
the environmental
control and life support
system for urine processing.
It fouled nearly immediately
when it got up there
because it wasn't
built to handle
the large amounts of calcium
that the crew was dumping out
every day.
But through some-- through
the right ratios of protein
and potassium, and serious
amounts of time exercising,
we think we've overcome most
of those issues for the crew.
And we'll see
whether that ends up
helping my grandmother or
somebody else's grandmother
later on.
And that's one of the ways that
it actually does transition
into an Earth benefit when we
research these type of things.
Plenty of physical sciences
work that's up there.
So I didn't make this
particular slide,
and this one often turns--
to me, it was a little hokey,
but you guys all understand
there's no convection in space
because there's
no gravity, right?
But the thing that I
didn't even realize
until a couple years
ago was that we
don't have any data
on, for instance,
large-scale combustion.
And we've done a lot of
work on flames in space,
but it's all been very
small, very contained.
And so we're going to
do some large-scale fire
tests using ISS.
And at first, when I first
heard of it, I thought,
we're going to do some
big "Wrath of Khan"
glowing orb that is going
to burn up out of the sky.
This is going to be the
coolest looking thing.
It's not going to be
that cool looking.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to take the
orbital Cygnus vehicle.
That is a vehicle that normally
burns up when it returns.
So we have two
commercial cargo vehicles
that I mentioned from
the United States.
SpaceX has a heat shield
and is recoverable,
and we bring back science to
do analysis on the ground.
The orbital vehicle right
now is designed to burn up.
So we put garbage
and other things
that we want to get rid
of into that vehicle,
and it hits the atmosphere at
the right angle so it burns up.
But we're going to
take a large part
of the inside of that vehicle.
I thought we were going to set
the whole thing on fire when
the proposal came to me.
But they're going to
do it multiple times
on multiple return missions
of the orbital Cygnus,
and we're going to
get data from it.
And it's just going to be a
large box on the inside that's
burning within the box.
So it'll still be a
controlled reentry.
Everything will be
fine, and it will
be far less like the movies.
But it's still going to be
very interesting data for that.
Astrophysics and
fundamental physics--
so way out of my league
with this type of stuff,
but-- so we got a
guy named Sam Ting,
who's got a Nobel
Prize at home, who
came up with this
particular effort.
He realized that
this was the only way
he was going to get this
particular research done.
He's looking at dark matter.
We got a special
spot right for him.
He ended up
redesigning everything
to have a permanent magnet
instead of electromagnet.
This has been the work
of thousands of people
just for this one
particular experiment.
And we'll see if he
doubles up on his prizes
by the time he gets
all this data together
and get all his
publications out.
And this is the type of
stuff that he's looking at.
I'm not sure-- this doesn't have
the info on the number of hits.
So the number of data
samples that they announced
that they've had through AMS
is almost getting silly now.
I think it's-- I can't
remember to which power it is,
but it's at least 10 to the 20th
number of hits and particles
that they're taking.
And so there's vast
number crunching
that goes on with trying to
decide what they can infer
from all this data
that they're getting.
And so most of that is to come.
OK, well, so now more
into the area that I am.
I'm an engineer, so
most of the stuff
that I have a little bit
better understanding for
is in the area of
technology and engineering.
So we do some stuff
up there with that.
We got the Robonaut
Project Manager right here,
Ron Diffler, and that's
one of the things
that we've done up there.
And there's a lot that
we have to figure out
if we're going to
go somewhere else.
So we got the ISS there now, and
it's state of the art, right?
There's really no better space
vehicle that's flying anywhere,
regardless of the fact that
we've got older laptops
and we've got
computers that we call
MDMs that are running--
what are they running?
AUDIENCE: 286s.
GEORGE NELSON: Yeah,
286s or something.
I mean, so they're
very reliable.
They're rad-hardened,
and they do very well.
But it's the state
of the system,
and it's built specifically--
the whole vehicle is built
to be where it is,
in low earth orbit,
where we can launch a
Soyuz or maybe later
on a commercial crew
vehicle or something else
and get there very quickly.
Or in a real
emergency, the crew can
come home, no problem,
very quickly in the Soyuz.
But if we're going to go for a
long time a long distance away,
there are other things
that we want to do,
and we want to use the
Space Station to prove out
all of the technology
that we need for that.
We don't want to find
out halfway to Mars
the urine processor
doesn't work.
That's not so great.
So we tried to come
up with, all right, so
what things do we
want to do up there?
And obviously, any
engineer in this room
could probably come up with
most of the general areas
that we needed to do.
Figure out your environment.
Get your reliability
where it needs to be.
Look at the logistics
that you do or don't
need for the mission
that you're potentially
going to do and reduce that risk
implementing it somewhere else.
So we came up with
a bunch of areas,
and we use the National Academy
of Sciences, the National
Research Council-- the
agency does-- to tell us
what to do a lot.
On the science side, they have
something called the Decadal
Survey, and that's
like their bible.
If it's not in the
Decadal Survey,
you're not going to
see the science mission
director as spending
money on it.
On the tech side,
we also get inputs
from the National Academy.
And the underlined
ones are the ones
that they had recommended
that we focus on.
Or the underlying ones are
the specific experiments
that address areas that we
were told to concentrate on.
But a lot of them
don't necessarily
complete the problem.
They don't put to
bed the problem.
So we started throughout--
with all our partners,
we got these teams together.
And we said, OK, we're going to
figure out and prioritize what
we're going to use ISS for
for technology demonstrations.
And we all sat down, and we
came up with all the areas
that we thought we
were going to come up
with in the first place.
And we did prioritize ECLSS,
the Environmental Control
and Life Support
Systems, as the top one.
So we have a lot of
consumables that we end up
using with the ISS
version of ECLSS.
We end up relying
upon a logistics
train, the resupply vehicles
that we have for that ECLSS.
There's things that
we need to do in order
to go to Mars, for
instance, with ECLSS,
and we can identify those.
So that was good.
And then on the
radiation side of things,
we said we need to figure
this out too because it's
a different radiation
environment once you get
outside the Van Allen
belts, and we've
got to know all about that.
And so when we looked at
it, we had a million options
on what to do for Environmental
Control and Life Support
Systems.
And all of us were
well-rounded generalists
in the areas of
space technology.
And we didn't think it was
really fair for the six
or seven of us that
were tasked to this team
to make these large decisions.
On top of that, it's a political
environment that you have,
right?
So you have one idea
that comes from Alabama.
You get another one
that comes from Ohio.
that comes from Texas.
And no matter which
one you choose,
somebody says, well,
the reason they
chose that is because of this.
And then somebody calls an
elected official, and then
all of a sudden, you're
designing your spacecraft
inside the beltway instead
of where it needs to be,
on a drafting table or the
modern equivalent of it.
So what we did is we
said, all right, we're
going to set up
teams, and we're going
to use them in the exact same
way that the rest of the agency
uses, the NRC and the
National Academies,
and tell us what's going on,
because while on the ECLSS side
we had a million options,
on the radiation side,
we had a real lack of options.
We sensed the heck out
of radiation up there,
and that's what all
the proposals were--
sensing, sensing,
sensing, sensing.
So we're going to be able to
tell a crew you're smoked,
but I'm not sure how we can
tell them, but you'll be OK.
So that's one of the
things that we've
tasked that
particular team with,
and we've called them
system maturation teams.
And we've set one up for ECLSS.
We set one up for comm and nav.
We set one up for
radiation, and we
set one up-- the human
research program really already
existed before this, so
we said, hey, you guys,
make sure you
concentrate on that.
So we did that for all
the technical areas so
that we could properly
identify-- and we told them,
we just want you to evaluate
the technical solutions.
First identify the
technical gaps,
and then help us
identify the solutions.
And we're trying to
take any politics out
of it as to whose idea--
so we have experts
from across the agency.
We populated it
from every center.
And when they come
to a consensus,
we've got it so that the
technology investment
teams within the
agency and the programs
can say, well, what does
the SMT think about this?
And they say, oh, they think
this is their top priority.
And that's how we get
things funded, and flown,
and executed.
And it's important because
if you've paid attention
to any federal budget discussion
over the last few years,
it's a zero sum game, right?
So if we end up choosing
the wrong thing to invest in
and it costs X dollars, those
dollars are gone, right?
And it can't be used to
spend on something else.
So when we look at the
technical gaps that we have,
we have to agree that
they're general enough
that they should be
addressed now before Congress
or a president tells,
us this is your mission,
because everything we're doing
now is based on a generality.
We know we want to go
out there somewhere.
So we look at all the generic
solutions to these technology
problems and prioritize
filling in those gaps
based on what you need--
the lead time in order
to develop them.
If you know you need four
years on an ECLSS system,
well, you better make sure you
have four years left of ISS
by the time you fly it in order
to vet it out and then make
any mods that you need
to once you're there.
And we're trying to get
the teams to develop--
and some of them have already--
specific roadmaps so that we
can then say, you know what?
We're done with
the Space Station.
We've met every goal-- check,
check, check, check, check.
And we can hand it over
to commercial entities,
or we can simply-- let's
transition to deep space
because we've managed
to address what
we need to, using this vehicle.
An important thing
to understand is
that people look at
things differently
depending on who you are.
And actually, it's
missing-- there we go.
OK, so depending
on who you are, you
might look at the flow of
how the space station got up
there a little differently.
If you were building it, if
you were part of the project
management, you design it,
and then you assemble it.
And then you start using it,
and then you think about, OK,
do we need to use it for
a longer period of time,
or are we good?
Then you worry about extension.
If you're on the science
side, well, in the design,
people are telling
me that there's
going to be a Space Station.
Let's hold off and see if
one actually gets built.
And then we start building it,
and they're like, all right.
Well, let's wait
until it finishes.
And then, OK, you
guys are really done?
OK, go right ahead.
And we really saw that.
We saw this gap.
After we were finished building
it, we turned around and said,
who wants to use it?
And there hadn't
been this backlog
of science waiting to use
the ISS because that's not
the way that you get your
research funded, is by saying
I'm going to go
do some research.
I'd like you to give me
several million dollars,
and I'm going to conduct it on
that vehicle that doesn't yet
exist.
So we had to wait.
First, we had to promise
that it got up there.
Then, we had to deliver it.
And now, we're seeing a lot
more usage and requests for use
now that it's been there
and it's a proven commodity.
And then, if you're just
in the organization, first,
you worried about
all the requirements
and how to get the things done.
Then you worried about
building the vehicle
and getting the crew there.
And this is the transition that
I was talking about before,
this changing your
focus to research.
And then, OK, are we going
to continue that or not?
And then, this kind of
just mentions the things
that I've already talked about.
With operating safely,
it's probably not enough.
You need to take
enough of a risk
so that you get the proper
return on the investment.
And it's what I was
talking about before,
that it's a real
laboratory, and it's OK
if things don't work
the first time--
and getting people to
accept the fact that that's
perfectly acceptable.
OK, so I mentioned some
Earth science stuff before
and said that I
would talk about it.
So it turns out it's a
really great platform.
So I mentioned that we are
at a higher inclination
than a lot of space
shuttle flights would take.
So we would launch
out of Florida,
and so you would--
from that latitude,
you would get to
a higher altitude
by staying at that
latitude, instead
of going to a higher one.
And that's probably
where ISS would
have been if it was just Space
Station Freedom, a sole United
States effort.
But because we wanted to
have access by our partners
to the vehicle, we're
at a higher inclination,
which ends up providing a lot
more access and a lot more
visibility to the ground that
we wouldn't have had otherwise.
So you end up covering
85% of the Earth's surface
flying over it, where
you wouldn't have.
You'd have been kind
of skinny, down,
no further north than Florida.
And then, every one
to three days, you
end up passing over 95%
of the world's population.
So not only is it
International Space Station
because of investment, but it's
international in that if you
go to your computer and
you look up ISS sightings,
you can see it go right
over your head often.
And it can make observations
of where you live,
which could be
significant as well.
Some of those observations can
be in the hyperspectral zone.
So this is looking
at a lot of stuff,
whether it be ocean temperatures
or reactions of the ocean
to changing
temperatures, or it could
be-- we've had agriculture
requests to look at things
like the Napa Valley for the way
that agriculture is responding
or not to climate.
I mentioned the
relativistic aspect of it.
So in 2016, the ESA is
going to fly the ACES.
So this is an atomic clock.
It's going to have two
clocks in it, actually.
One is going to be based
on cesium atoms, I think,
and I can't remember
what the other side is.
But between the
two clocks, they'll
have an accuracy of
better than one second
for 300 million years.
And so they're going to compare
that to very accurate clocks
on the ground and end up
proving out some Einstein stuff,
or maybe proving it
to be debatable--
but between gravitation
and relativistic time.
So even before we
said, hey, everybody,
it's open for use, open for
business, come and use it,
we'd already done some
significant things really
in the spare time.
We were spending a lot
of time building it,
but in the spare
time, we still managed
to do quite a lot of stuff.
MAXI was a joint venture
with JAXA and us,
and so they were able to
observe and complement
another observation of a
black hole swallowing a star.
It was the first time
that had been done.
They noticed something
with the crew,
that there were certain
crew members that
were coming back
with vision issues.
So they realized
that it might be--
it's environmental for sure, but
it might affect specific crew
members more than others.
So we've been looking
at that and whether it's
intracranial pressure or whether
it's a gene expression type
thing.
Microbial virulence--
so that's what
I mentioned before about
the stressor on everything,
not just cells but
microbes as well.
And so there's some--
resulting from that,
there's some candidate
vaccines for different things
that have been out there.
And I removed the slide
from it, but there's
that valley of death for
technologies and science
research that comes out, right?
So there's this rush up
with results that end up
being obtained
from all this work,
and then getting across
that final valley
to-- whether it be
something that you
can do a human
research trial on,
or whether it's a true
commercial product or anything,
you've got to get
across that big hurdle.
So you can hear a lot of
stuff that gets to the point
that I'm talking about
right there that never gets
into a hospital or into Best
Buy or somewhere like that.
Let's see.
The NASA exploration
mission side--
that's largely what we're
tasking the SMTs to help us
come up with the proper
investments to do,
and they're well on
their way to doing that.
We have had some spin-offs
in technology area,
like robotic assist
for brain surgery.
There's a need for
telemedicine when
it comes to having a crew
being that far away from Earth.
There's filtering for
air that has come out.
You need the crew to breathe
the same air all the time,
and it's got to be
compatible with human life.
And then, let's see-- the last
one, remotely-guided ultrasound
for maternal care-- another
telemedicine application.
So my original question, or
title, was how best to use.
So here's some final points
on how I would best use it
and my recommendations for it.
So prioritize your
resources of limited life.
So the saying that a lot
of people in the NASA area
have heard me use a lot was
use the Space Station now.
The ground's going
to be here forever.
So there's a premise that
you can't fly something
until you're ready to
fly because I can't
be that guy that people
are talking about
that it didn't work
the first time.
We flew a carbon dioxide removal
solution called Amine Swingbed,
which was going to be applicable
to the next Orion vehicle
that we're building.
And we built it--
by NASA standards,
we built it on the cheap.
And it flew up there,
and it didn't work.
And we ended up using
the crew to fix it,
and it wasn't a small amount.
It wasn't a small amount of
time that we ended up doing it.
And we considered
bringing it home,
which was also another
acceptable solution.
We've paid for the logistics
so you can fly something there.
If it really doesn't work and it
really can't be fixed on orbit,
we'll fly it home.
We'll tweak it and
fly it again if it's
of the right priority
and the right need
for either you, the
country, or the agency.
So prioritize the
work that you're doing
and fund it appropriately.
You don't need to
overspend, and I
don't recommend underspending.
Force the institutional
change that's required.
So we did the
reorganization that we need.
We're redesigning
processes still every day.
There's a specific
team at JSC right now
that is changing the entire
process by which we accept
experiments to ISS because we
deemed it as too expensive,
as did some of our customers.
If you guys are
providing products
that are too expensive
for people to use,
you're going to make a change.
Well, as a government
agency, there's
not always the same impetus.
But we have enough people
that care enough about this
that we're doing exactly that.
And then, change the perceptions
of your organization--
how they perceive everybody who
is going to be their customer.
Have a plan and measure
your performance to it.
That might scare people who are
big on fundamental research.
It doesn't have to be the
results that you plan for.
It just needs to be
planning appropriately
for what you want to
investigate and explore.
On the tech side, we
have specific goals
that we need to get to.
Embrace the private sector.
So we're certainly doing
that in the logistics train.
We don't have any
NASA-owned assets,
and that's been
something to get used to.
We pay SpaceX and Orbital
to get stuff there and back.
And for now, we pay
the Russians for humans
to get there and back.
So I think we're doing that.
And the part that
I discussed before
about trying to get American
entities to recognize the Space
Station is there for them.
They can keep all their
intellectual property.
And we assume,
effectively, all the risk
if you build the
hardware, getting
that word out is important.
And then, getting
word out-- it's
really important that people
understand the benefits
that we're getting.
So if you have people
that are properly
reporting the work that
they do, whether it's
something as significant as
"Origin of Species" or not,
it's important for
people to understand
this was possible
because of this asset,
and it's good that our elected
officials can understand,
all right, this is something
that is actually benefiting
people in my district, people
on-- people in this state,
or just people on
the Earth in general.
So increasing the public
knowledge is a real thing,
and even that is of
benefit to everybody here.
So that's all I had, and so I
can open it up to questions.
AUDIENCE: So it's kind of
a double-track question,
but I don't hear much about
the International Space Station
in the media.
And in parallel, we had
Maria Klawe here last week
talking about building
inclusive environments
and getting more women
and minorities involved
in STEM and CS.
I don't in any way mean
to propose doing crass dog
and pony shows with the
International Space Station,
but do you have
an outreach effort
to try to get kids
of all backgrounds
from all around the
world excited about what
the International
Space Station is doing
and engaged with the experiments
that are happening there?
GEORGE NELSON: Well, very
honestly, it's not something
that, historically,
NASA's done very well,
just outreach in general.
And I think that when you
have the type of people
that NASA historically
has been attractive to,
they're all about
the mission, right?
And so if you go
to the moon, that's
going to get people excited.
But when you talk
about science research,
I think of that "Big Bang"
episode where they're like,
let's get to work, and they
play the theme to "Rocky"
while they stare at a
white board for an hour.
That doesn't always get
people excited, right?
So I think one of the best
outreach activities that ISS
has had has been through
YouTube and Google,
when they were able to
get-- I can't remember
how many proposals they
got, but they ended up
selecting two to fly on ISS.
That's not an
insignificant thing,
particularly for those kids
that managed to do it--
and exposed everybody
who even tried
to be selected to the process
of developing and proposing
scientific activities.
I think that's great.
We recently had a three-day--
it wasn't really a retreat,
but we had a three-day
discussion with ISS leadership
recently.
And that was one of the
things that we talked about,
was the outreach aspect.
And making sure that people
understand everything
is really part of
all of our jobs.
So that's one of the
reasons I'm here.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
a couple of times
that the resource
is limited, that it
would have an end of
life at some point.
Could you tell me when that is?
And then, what is
NASA considering
for-- as it develops larger
and perhaps more complex
space stations?
GEORGE NELSON: Well,
so I was talking
to-- it's kind of a
complicated answer
as to what the Space Station
life is right now because you
have so many different
political entities that
are involved with it.
So 2016 was the original date.
The United States
has approved 2020.
Our partners are working
on approving 2020,
but there is general acceptance
within, for instance,
my colleagues within the
Space Station program
from other countries
that it's 2020.
The current
administration has said
that they are good
with it being to 2024.
There's a general
rule-- shocking
that they follow any
rules consistently--
but there's a general
rule within the beltway
that you don't commit two
administrations beyond you
to anything.
So it's not law, but 2024
is the general acceptance
within the United States
as to how long we're
going to have and use the ISS.
And then, everybody
within the program
itself has been working to
certify all of the hardware
to make sure that
the vehicle itself
can last at least until 2028.
So we think we have
a reasonable future
in being able to provide
a product to customers
that are out there.
And it's important that people
understand that that horizon is
well down the road, because
a lot of these investments
take several years to first
fund and then build and then
fly and then re-fly,
if they need to.
So assuring people that we're
going to be there for a while,
I think, is an important
thing to get across.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, saying
2016 would probably
kill most people's
consideration.
GEORGE NELSON:
Yeah, we addressed
that pretty early
on after assembly
complete that in order
to do what we need to do,
it needed to be minimum 2020.
We got concurrence
with that, and then
general concurrence on
we're looking at 2024.
And then, the whole
time-- you don't
get to go beyond 2024 if that
is what your goal is, right?
So we're trying to make
sure that everything
is capable of sustaining
flight well beyond 2028.
AUDIENCE: So the
next step for NASA
is not necessarily another
space station, but more along
the lines of a trip to Mars.
Is that what I'm hearing?
GEORGE NELSON: I think
that is the general-- you
can get in trouble by saying
this is what we are or aren't
doing these days, but
the general consensus
is that all of the prep
work that we're doing,
particularly in tech
and human research,
is to enable a trip to Mars.
Now, whether you do that by
making a pit stop at the moon,
or whether you do some asteroid
work first, or wherever,
it doesn't seem to be
offensive to anybody
to say that's an
eventual destination.
And it happens to
be really hard,
so all of the tech
solutions that we have
are really bounded by
that extreme of trying
to go to Mars.
AUDIENCE: Do you have an updated
take on Kessler syndrome?
And is there a way that
newer satellite companies
like Skybox and things like
that change that equation?
GEORGE NELSON: Well, so the
access of other companies
is there.
I don't know if you
heard that part.
I'm not good to be
able to give you
an update on any of that stuff.
But the access of private
entities to ISS is established,
and it's a really
open road to get there
through CASIS, the Center
for Advancement of Space
In Science.
And those guys can
help anybody get there.
The law is written that
half of the US assets
are designated a national lab.
They didn't
specifically tell us how
we were supposed to
measure that percentage,
or whether it was
measured on a monthly
or a yearly or a
five-year basis.
But we haven't really
approached 50% above mass
yet on each launch, so
there's plenty of room
there for private companies
to try and do stuff.
AUDIENCE: Just following up on
the question about lifetime,
what's the average proposal
to flight time for projects
that come into your office?
GEORGE NELSON: For the things
that come into our office,
there was-- when I said one
of the things about embracing
the commercial sector is we
had to let those guys get off
the ground, because
we didn't end up
starting with the-- it wasn't
Boeing and Lockheed that ended
up proposing to be the
commercial providers
for the commercial cargo.
So SpaceX had to start
from the beginning.
Orbital have to build their
whole vehicle themselves
as well.
So there was a significant
lag in our ability
to deliver hardware for a while
until they really got going.
So for instance, the cameras
that I showed when we first
got in here-- we were
racing to get those built,
just in case another payload
wasn't ready for SpaceX 3,
and that was in 2011.
And we didn't launch until
this year to get that going.
But now, I think we're
about to start cruising,
I think, with real
regular transport.
So it's quite variable when
you say, how long does it take?
Most of them are not-- that's
a very simple payload--
four cameras and a box outside.
Make sure that it doesn't
fall apart, right?
So that was very easy to build.
Most of them are not
waiting for a ride.
But for instance, the legs
that went on Robonaut,
those waited for a while.
And that particular
project needed
to figure out their
funding profile,
as they weren't
integrated at ISS.
And so that goes-- that falls
into part of my responsibility
when we prioritize the
work that gets done,
not just the up-mass, but
what the crew spends time on.
And that's part of the
discussion, when I say,
no, this has to be
the top priority
because that
researcher is losing
funding at the end
of this quarter,
so that's why it's the priority.
And so a loss of
science is a huge driver
in getting things done at ISS.
It's one of the reasons that
the human research program
gets so much time
because if you go
through five months of
a crew member on orbit
and you need the sixth month
in order to complete the run,
it's a complete loss of science.
This guy's coming home.
You can't do anything
else after that,
so that becomes a priority
in one of the discussions.
But we can get stuff--
the standard template is
18 months-- 18 months from when
you get effectively manifested
for that increment for that
period of time and then fly.
But you've got to be on dock--
it depends on the launch
provider, but you've
got to be on dock
usually 90 days ahead of launch.
AUDIENCE: So it seems like cost
is the primary limiting factor
on the lifespan of the ISS?
GEORGE NELSON: I'm
not sure that's true.
I mean, it has
to-- so whose cost?
So cost is a significant
factor in the investment
of the science that gets done.
Way back when a space
station was conceived,
there were going to
be two pots of money,
one to build and
operate the vehicle,
and a second pot to
do all the research.
Well, long ago, that
second pot failed to exist.
And so we're in a situation of
build it and they will come,
and part of that is
getting the word out.
So there is a nominal
amount of NASA's budget
that is required in order
to continue flying the ISS.
So that would be
required if it was
going to continue to
be a government asset.
It's possible, when NASA
has met all of its needs,
that it gets turned over
to a corporate entity that
manages to continue to use it.
Depending on when
that is, it might
be the hardware that's the
limiting factor on continuing
to use it.
AUDIENCE: And are
the costs going down
as companies like SpaceX
reduce cost to launch?
GEORGE NELSON: Well, I mean, we
only have one contract so far
for commercial cargo.
We were talking
earlier that we're
going to talk-- I
think there's a pending
announcement on commercial crew.
One of my bosses is
off doing the work
for the second iteration
of commercial cargo.
So to say that
anything's coming down
would have to await I'd say the
next iteration of contracting
to say that it's coming down.
But that's one of
the intents of using
the commercial
side of things, is
because they don't
require themselves
to adhere to the 40
years of bureaucracy
that we've set up for ourselves.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that next
round of contracts today?
GEORGE NELSON: It might be.
I haven't seen
whether they're going
to announce the-- you're
talking commercial crew?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE NELSON: OK.
For crew?
So that's the crew side.
There's another effort to do
the extension of the SpaceX
and Orbital aspect, the
commercial cargo side, that
is not limited to
those two to propose.
And so we'll wait and see
what the answers to that is.
I think the RFI was
about to go out--
or the RFP was about
to go out soon.
Well, thanks a lot
for coming, guys.
[APPLAUSE]